hello would you like me to read your
future hello I am Josh Hutcherson and I
am here today at BuzzFeed to play with
some
puppies bring in the monsters oh boy
hello hello hi oh yeah there we go oh
there's more you nervous me too your
tiny little
eyes this one reminds me of Jeremy Irons
Jeremy's a he's a dog guy actually every
day he would bring his dog with him two
set so that's a a perfectly appropriate
question for here and now but he's
amazing I mean the guy is like a legend
so intense and my character treats him
like the entire time so it was uh pretty
fun to get to boss him
around there's Now Toys being introduced
it was super fun I mean like I got to go
into like this whole other state of mind
that they never let me do cuz they
always want me to be the nice guy but
I'm really
so it was fun it was really fun to kind
of just jump into something so
different I didn't really watch anything
specifically but my uh my great grandma
actually fell victim to one of these
horrible fishing scams it's so soft I
have pites and they're shired so I don't
really get like cotton ball dogs very
often to like hold very nice um great
grandma got scammed it's so I mean they
try I'm sure all you guys have it happen
all the time just like the text of like
a package they went missing or like a
bank that I'm not even connected to is
like there's a fraud and I'm just like
yeah no but a 90-year-old Grandma who
like wanted to help who she thought was
her great-grandson it's it's
brutal come here and help me explain to
these people about my crazy wardrobe
you're the missing missing drop that's
why I would name you drop it was really
fun because uh getting to create a
character that's so bad and so rich and
privilege and has like no come yes I
know come here okay I'm going to play
with you while I hope hold them and
answer question this is you're you're
you're asking a lot the idea was like if
you had a guy that has no sense of
reality all the money in the world and
is trying to like exude uh a bunch of
confidence that he does not have you can
play with the boot absolutely these are
fun actually I chew on these all the
time yes so the idea was like if he is
trying to project all this confidence
he's a wildly insecure guy what would he
do and it was like mixing snakes skin
boots with like leopard leopard print
undershirts and then like greens and
Golds for me I think my favorite look
was when you first meet ER in his office
space he's got this like crazy like zip
up jumper print thing and then with the
hair and the diamond study I didn't like
him nobody likes him I like you
guys I mean the truth is my character
really doesn't do many stunts he's the
guy that like funds all the goons to go
get killed by Jason STM there's some
really cool stuff we shot we had like a
scene where like a marine one US
Government helicopter flies in and they
got an actual Marine One helicopter and
we were in London so like they really
went for it you're a troublemaker I know
you're not the biggest in the world so
you're trying to make up for it with the
spunkiness for me it was really exciting
to work with Piper Rubio who plays my
little sister and she was amazing
because she was a huge uh FNAF fan so
she was the entire time losing her mind
with all the amazing puppets they did
and trying to explain to me all the
stuff like the Deep lore things and I
had no idea what she was talking about
but we had we had a really good time
working
[Music]
together it's kind of like trying to get
these three to stay together when they
just are all doing all kinds of other
crazy things and that's like me Jen and
Liam just like we're always like all
over the world in different places but
when we get together it's kind of like
similar to this Dynamic I'm that one I
think based in like size it's great
though they're still near and dear to me
right yep there you go that that was
Liam right there he just tumbled
over
dog movie next
question I kind of live under a rock in
that sense of like online stuff and yeah
the whistle mean was something I had no
idea what it was and then my girlfriend
like posted something on Instagram and
in the comments it was just like screen
grabs of this weird picture of me from
2015 and then we're like something's up
she I don't understand the internet I
was like yeah me neither and then during
the holidays my uh my
brother I need your emotional support
please and so they started showing me
just going through like this new version
of like a Rick Roll thing which is just
me from this random photo edit that they
made in 2014 the internet's a magical
place and then my friend Erica who is
actually here she told me like she never
sends me anything that she sees about me
online but she was like I had to send
you this one and it was the one where
Joe Biden has like a coffee mug and he
drinks it and then my head and that Meme
pops up I was like well now I've made
it
or the other like more subtle is
like I mean I loved when I got to do the
Pea sort of when he gets messed up with
the tracker Jacker Venom and all that
similar to like with beekeeper how I got
to just go to kind of a pretty wild
place with a character and be pretty
free with it doing that kind of thing
was a lot of fun
too that moment is kind of ridiculous we
shot that in like the the mountains
outside of like uh Asheville in North
Carolina there were a ton of snakes and
like they put me into like a rock
crevice that just looked like it went
infinitely back into like a dark snake
pit so I was I had to lay there for like
45 minutes while they did this whole
makeup thing on the face I didn't see
what it looked like cuz it was on me and
I didn't see a monitor or anything so I
saw playback after like when they were
showing me what it looked like and uh I
couldn't stop laughing cuz I was is like
how did he pull this off like with what
they were like he's a baker I'm like
yeah cool but like that's crazy they're
like it works I'm like all right I'm
just I'm just an actor I I'll shut up
but you know it's kind of kind of
crazy that was a super fun time we shot
that in New Zealand but when I was
shooting that movie our location was
like an hour and a half away from where
we were staying and because we were kids
you can only work certain hours of the
day and so for a week straight they flew
us to and from our homes in a helicopter
two set and I was like 12 years old
flying to work in a helicopter and
that's just like mind-blowing right like
if that doesn't warp your perspective on
reality what
will yeah actually when I was pretty
young there was one of the uh like home
alone but I was probably like 11 I think
maybe when I auditioned for it and it
got down between me and and the other
guy and uh that was like the first time
that I tasted like rejection so that was
really
hard just reliving the whole Hunger
Games experience again I would I would
go back to Pea in a heartbeat look at
this little hat we got for you now
hello would you like me to read your
future I don't even know where I
am on Hunger Games I took like the
little locket that Peta gives to Katniss
yeah actually just came across it the
other day too I was like cleaning stuff
out I think zura that's one that I guess
like and I guess like timing wise too A
lot of the people that when they watch
it they're like my age now so like in
their 30s and stuff and it's just really
funny they're like yo Zora was my movie
man I loved you in that I watched like a
h 100 times my boring stories are
putting you guys
[Music]
asleep I definitely want to direct and
and write as well I done a couple music
videos a short film being an actor is
amazing because the performance and
bringing up person to life and the
character creation everything but
there's so much that's out of your
control and like the storytelling which
take is even new score editing so many
things like that and I just loved my
experience that I had directing the few
things that I have and and definitely
want to explore more of
that I just watched jury duty I would
totally come and do like the James
Marsden guy like that like gets brought
into I would 100% do something like that
I think the idea of like blending like a
documentary type thing with like a
scripted thing is really
[Music]
fun yes have you ever said anything no
it it's it's so embarrassing I feel so
weird it actually happens quite a it
happened for quite a while cuz Hunger
Games made its like rounds on the I
think it's still on the planes and I've
definitely like got up and gone to the
bathroom and like walked by like six
screens that different points of The
Hunger Games I'm just like oh God oh God
oh
[Music]
God actually I was just talking with
somebody the other day a producer about
like types of movies that I kind of want
to you know look at moving forward and I
was like man I just saw like nodding
Hill for the first time and like that
kind of amazing great romantic comedy
hasn't really had a space in our world
right now and I think to try to find
something in that in that kind of genre
would be really really
fun
I am pretty much fluent yeah I I kind I
split my time between LA and uh Madrid
just as much time as I spend there it
was necessary for me to learn I'm super
happy cuz I shot a movie last uh June
like down in Columbia just to be able to
like communicate with people when you
travel and like their native language
you get such a more Rich experience also
of like connection and and and getting
into the cultures and stuff
so Lola Bunny that was a sort of
Awakening some might
call her less hot than the new one okay
that's probably for the better it was
like not
[Music]
okay I'm not I will look into this again
I don't go on the internet very often I
feel like a grandpa is the truth like
people talk about things I'm just like
man I don't know I was in bed at 8:45
last night like I'll check it out I hope
you learned something valuable here
today thanks for stopping by and please
make sure to go check out The Beekeeper
it is in theaters right now all of these
puppies are available for adoption at
Northshore Animal League
[Music]
America